we're gonna take a look at ami
horowitz's new video ami
went around new york asking people on
the street if the richest people in
america are paying their fair
share in taxes you can check out the
full video over at daily wires youtube
page
let's get started i'm ami horowitz and
the mantra the left is that the rich
don't pay their fair share in taxes
let's go find that if that's true do you
think the rich
pay their fair share in taxes
[Laughter]
do the rich pay their fair share in
taxes absolutely not
in america in the united states
absolutely not probably not fair if all
things are considered
absolutely not absolutely not no no
no absolutely not no absolutely not
absolutely not yeah no definitely not
not not even close the problem with a
lot of them is that they just would
rather
be they'd rather be dead and see poor
people be rich or be well off
i mean i i know people in america think
of gaddafi as a negative guy but let's
go back to libya
libya free education free electricity
now if you're slaughtering people the
streets
are slaughtering people in the stream
six of this half dozen other i just
think capitalism is stupid
and it doesn't work i mean obviously
look at our country it doesn't work
okay can we pause it there for one
second my favorite is when people
who are wearing things that they bought
at a store that are much nicer than
anything they could get in a communist
country
are like capitalism obviously doesn't
work she said while wearing a sweatshirt
that she got at a store
and sunglasses she got at a store and
carrying a purse that she got
at a store yes communism is obvious
just look at our country it doesn't work
um yes
how is it possible for billionaires to
even exist
in this country and you've got the most
most starving
suffering people on the in in the
richest country in the world no way
you come from zimbabwe more people are
starving than bob with it here they sold
me a
lemon okay stop there wait if you come
from zimbabwe to the united states and
then you think that you were sold to
lebanon
you're not on this planet zimbabwe is
one of the worst
places to live on the planet also like
i noticed that you have some sunglasses
nice nike sweatshirt right there like
the the notion that that other places
around the world
are better than the united states is
rooted in either insanity or
complete ignorance we have the most
starving people on the planet
no we absolutely 100 do not
we do not have nearly the number of
starving people that pretty much every
other country on the planet
has which is why people were clamoring
to get here i noticed there was not a
lot of reverse immigration from the
united states to zimbabwe for example
i just think people shouldn't even be
able to make as much money as they do
do you think there should be a cap on
income yes fully
what we're looking at is surfton what
percentage should be paid by the top one
percent
probably 60 70 or 80 percent
if they could kick it up to 75 to 80
that would be good man
hit them up for 80 they need to be
freaking touched
what's wrong with 90 percent is i like
you
i love you man ninety percent that's
ninety percent ninety five percent
dude they live on five percent i think
they can live on five percent man i get
where you going with this man i i
totally agree
99 of their wealth why should people
with less money be paying
more than billionaires when they
literally don't have that money to pay
in the first place
why do you think it makes me sad for
democracy i mean truly this makes me sad
for democracy that people want to make
tax policy like what do you think that
people who are richer than you should
pay
everything 120 of their wealth why
should they have more money than i
am i mean here i am in the middle of the
day in a park
i assume this is a work day like maybe
they have more money than you because
they're not
walking around in a park in the middle
of the day maybe
hmm so do you think that the poor pay a
higher percentage of their income
yes or the rich they do pay higher
percentage yeah they do yeah oh the
lower class
definitely pay more yeah lower income
people poor people the one percent earn
about 25
of all the income in america so there
you go if we're talking about fair share
right then you know if you're bringing
in 25 of the income
25 of the taxes should also that would
be coming yeah i would say
so yeah and would you be surprised if i
told you that the
top one percent paid 40 of all taxes
yeah would it surprise you if i said the
rich the one percent
pay 40 of all taxes in america
interesting what surprised me
yeah yeah really interesting it's a
little a little more fair than you might
have thought
yeah what percent of income
do you think the top one percent pay i
think they're paying like freaking
two
do you think people at the 50 and below
pay probably higher than 27
it gets higher the lower your income
comes waste the weight of the numbers
i think it's probably over 50. it's four
percent
oh wow interesting
i love that interesting is the code word
for i'm an idiot
interesting is like oh that is
interesting hmm
well i mean i'm still gonna vote for all
the same politicians who've been lying
to me
and i'm still gonna say next time
somebody asked me on the street that the
rich would pay more taxes but
it is interesting that you're completely
exploding my world view with like one
sentence
[Music]
sure interesting interesting interesting
and always interesting
yeah that sounds fair man yeah
i i need to i need to study up more on
this man good for him
all right seriously good for that guy
all right numbers did that surprise you
yes does that seem more fair
uh that yeah it would be pretty fair
oh wow yes i would i didn't know that
is that surprising yes does that seem
more fair because i feel like it's
i mean well yeah it would definitely
seem fair tell me that's the reality 100
well i'm shocked
i'm shocked seems like the bottom should
pay a little more
well oops well oops
as you can see a huge number of
americans know nothing
about the actual tax rates in the united
states all they know is what the media
keeps saying over and over
and they were the bernie sanders told
them that the which i'm paying the
fesher
even though i have three houses and they
know that alexander ocasio-cortez is
like well
that's what they know those are all the
things they know they don't know any of
the actual stats
which is why we have to remind them of
the actual stats like this one
according to the congressional budget
office report on distribution of taxes
in 2013
the top one percent of households paid
34 of their income to federal taxes
the middle 20 paid 12.8 percent the top
of income households they paid an
average in 2013 of almost 60
000 into federal tax coffers when you
include any wealth transfers they were
paid by the government
the fourth highest quintile meaning like
the people between
20 and 40 percent they paid like 2 600
bucks
the middle quintile actually made money
from the feds
and the second lowest quintile made
twelve thousand two hundred dollars
the lowest quintile made like almost
nine thousand dollars from the federal
government
here's the bottom line according to the
american enterprise institute
the highest income quintile like the top
20 are financing 100
of the entire system of transfer
payments to the bottom 60
and also funding the entire operation of
the federal government
so yeah actually it turns out that if
you were to compare
the united states to for example europe
we have the most progressive federal tax
system among
all oecd 24 countries
because we don't tax poor people and we
tax very very rich people
extraordinarily highly
everybody wants to live like denmark
without getting taxed like denmark the
thing about living like denmark is that
you also have to tax people at middle
income
at extraordinarily high rates but nobody
wants to do that so they just
lie there's and moan about the
rich and it's the rich to this and the
rich that
at a certain point the rich will just go
galt and then you're all gonna be left
to fend for yourselves is sort of the
way things are probably gonna go and a
quick note
good on some of these people for
actually acknowledging that they were
wrong about all of this
now we'll see if that actually
translates into stopping their vote
patterns
don't vote for democrats who lie to you
should be the message thanks for taking
a look at this video with me if you want
to check out the entire ami horowitz
video head on over to dailywire.com